One announcement,
there will be a weekly quiz on
Tuesday based on homework nine,
which will cover glasses and
chemical kinetics.
Speaking of which,
that's something we started talking
about last day,
I found this cute quote,
that kinetics is nature's way of
making sure that everything doesn't
happen all at once.
And, we looked at the rate laws,
the most general rate law is shown
here, the rate of consumption of a
particular reactant goes has some
function of its instant
concentration raised to the power,
, wnhich is the order of reaction.
The specific chemical rate constant,
k, is the proportionality. And, k
can be influenced by temperature
through this Arrhenius type
relationship, which compares the
exponential of the activation energy
with the available thermal energy.
And, we saw that we can integrate
that rate equation,
and put the data to the test.
If we have a first-order reaction,
we should get a semi-log dependence.
And, I think I've got that shown
here. Here's the data that I showed
you last day. This is just a normal
decrease in concentration with time,
typical attenuation curve. If we
put it to the first-order test,
according to this relationship we
should get a straight line with a
slope of minus k.
And, we saw that in the special
case of first-order actions,
it makes sense sometimes to talk
about half-life in particular with
radioactive decay.
We also looked at second-order
reactions, which have a slightly
different functional dependence
shown here. And,
then we went back and looked at the
underlying physical chemistry of the
activation energy.
And, we came up with this model,
which we presented in terms of
mechanical analog.
And, we saw that we could look at
the decrease in chemical potential
as not being monotonic but as
requiring some initial activation.
And so, we have here to energy state
of the reactants at one value,
the energy state of the products at
a lower value,
and the difference between those
values is the driving force for the
reaction, the delta E of the
reaction. But,
in order to get from the reactant
state to the product state,
we first have to activate. And
physically, there are a number of
things that are going on,
and at the end of the lecture I'll
show you an example with reference
to an automobile exhaust catalyst,
what is happening in terms of
forming some kind of activated
complex, which allows the reactants
to reorganize themselves so that
they can recognize that there is an
energy to be gained by their
reacting with one another,
and how a catalyst facilitates this.
And specifically,
we see that there is a tiny,
tiny fraction of the population
distribution that has enough energy
to surmount the activation barrier
and the inhibitor and the catalyst
respectively either impede the
reaction by raising the effective
activation energy,
thereby lopping off an even greater
amount of the distribution,
or facilitate the reaction by
lowering the activation energy,
thereby making a greater fraction of
the thermal distribution available
for participation in the reaction.
And, I think that's where we left it
last day. And so,
today what I'd like to do is to
continue the whole discussion of
what is broadly termed
rate phenomena.
So, chemical kinetics is part of a
unit here in 3.
91 that I'm going to call rate
processes. And,
rate processes are basically
processes that involve rate of
change with respect to time.
And, so one of course is chemical
kinetics. And we just spent some
time looking at chemical kinetics.
But, there's another area that we
want to touch upon,
and it's an area called transport
phenomena. And,
there's a reason for talking about
this. When we think about how we're
going to process materials in order
to achieve solids with desired
properties, we have to think about
the two basics that are required to
sustain a reaction.
And those are matter and energy.
So, let's look at what's involved in
each of these,
matter and energy.
We have to furnish these to the
reaction. And so,
if we're going to think about energy
in terms of transport phenomena,
that gets us into heat transfer.
But, we're not going to discuss heat
transfer in 3.
91. I can't do everything.
Instead, what we're going to do is
we're going to look at something
that's representative of transport
phenomena and we're going to look at
mass transport.
And mathematically there are many
parallels between heat transfer and
mass transport.
When we talk about mass transport,
if we're trying to drive a reaction,
we have to do two things. We had to
deliver reactants to the site,
and we have to remove products from
the site. If we don't do both,
the reaction could either starve or
choke. And, we saw a good example
of that early in the semester when
we talked about the Hindenburg.
The Hindenburg was a good example
of a reaction that had a huge
driving force of hydrogen explosion.
But, the Hindenburg did not explode
because we had 7,
00,000 cubic feet of hydrogen.
And, in order for that to react
explosively, we would have had to
deliver 7,000,
00 cubic feet of oxygen
instantaneously.
And we couldn't do that.
We could not do that, so because
the reaction was starved thanks to a
transport phenomena problem,
instead of an explosion, what we got
was a burn.
And, as a result,
two thirds of the occupants of the
vessel were able to walk off it.
And, not so many perished as
otherwise would have.
So, transport phenomena,
clearly important. And, the
dominant form of mass transport in
solids is diffusion.
So, when we're talking about mass
transport in solids,
we have to talk about diffusion.
And that's why we're going to do it.
So, let's think of an example.
Suppose I've got this wafer of
silicon.
And we've talked about doping.
We've talked about doping. Suppose
I want to render it p type.
So, what I want to do is I want to
infuse this with a subvalent dopant
such as boron.
So, how do we do that?
Do we smear this with boron and
just wait? What's the process?
Well, let's take a look more
closely. What we can do is we can
take our wafer,
and I'm going to exaggerate the
dimensions. So,
it's going to look more like a
hockey puck than a silicon wafer.
So, here's the silicon,
and we're going to put this into a
furnace. And,
we want to get boron into the wafer.
And, we are not going to do this by
melting. We're going to do this
while the wafer is the solid state.
That's why we're over here talking
about diffusion.
It's a solid-state process.
So, what we do is pass a form of
boron over the wafer as the gas
diborane. And,
the diborane passes over,
and on contact with the silicon is
decomposes to form boron,
which goes into the silicon,
plus hydrogen.
And that hydrogen,
of course, remains in the gas phase.
And, we could even write a rate
constant because this is a chemical
reaction. This is the composition
of diborane into hydrogen and boron,
and we could even take a guess that
the rate of this,
I haven't measured it,
but the rate would go as some
relationship involving the
concentration of diborane
to some power, n.
So, we've seen that,
but now I want to do is I want to
ask, what is the process by which
boron enters the silicon?
So, now I want to zoom in here to
the near surface.
And here's the free surface of
silicon. This is the surface.
This is inside the wafer. And,
I've got boron that's decomposing
and dissolving.
Remember, it goes up
substitutionally, sitting
on silicon sites.
So, now I'm asking,
how does the boron enter the silicon?
What are the kinetics of the
ingress of boron?
So, that's what we want to ask:
rate of ingress of boron through
silicon. That's what we want to
look at. And,
this is not some kind of a
cooperative process because
the silicon is solid.
So, individual atoms have to move
step by step through because it's a
substitutional solution that's
forming here. So,
we can take a guess at it.
If I now make this the coordinate
system, call the free surface x
equals zero, and this is moving down
into greater depth.
I can make a plot of ingress of
boron into silicon.
So, this is x which is depth from
surface. This is the free surface
at x equals zero.
And, I'm going to fix the
concentration of diborane in the
reactor. And so,
the concentration of boron at the
surface will be fixed.
As long as I keep the concentration
of diborane fixed,
concentration of boron at the
surface will be fixed.
So, what I'm going to do is plot
the concentration of boron in the
silicon as a function of
depth from the surface.
And, we know deep inside the silicon,
there's no boron.
So, here it should be zero.
We know at the surface it's
constant. The question is,
what is the shape of the curve?
Just as I showed you last day, we
talked about first order,
second order. What it boils down to
is, what is the shape of the curve?
And, we know it's going to look
something like this.
Doesn't that look a lot like the
attenuation curve for the loss of
matter in a chemical reaction?
It starts at some constant value and
trails off asymptotically.
So, really the question is,
what is the shape? And, how do we
answer that question?
We can't look at this and eyeball
it. Instead, what we do is we do a
new mapping. Map concentration into
some function of concentration.
Map depth into some function of
depth such that I will
get a straight line.
And then I can,
with the naked eye,
say, I've got it. I know what's
going on here.
And so, therefore,
the model that transformed c into f
of c, x into g of x,
then underlies the whole
representation.
And so, the mathematical
formulation of diffusion we owe to
someone by the name of Adolf Fick.
He was a physician.
But he loved mathematics.
And, he did to diffusion what
Balmer did to spectroscopy.
Recall, Balmer studied the
measurements that were made by
Angstrom. And it was Balmer who fit
Angstrom's data to that equation
that ultimately we learned to be in
concert with the Rydberg Equation.
What Fick did: he looked at Thomas
Graham's.
Thomas Graham had published some
diffusion data for the rate of
ingress of some materials into
aqueous media.
And, Fick was the one who was able
to fit Thomas Graham's data and give
us a model. And,
here is, let's jump through here.
This is the cover page. This is
the first page of the paper.
This was published in Annalen der
Physik und Chemie in Leipzig, 1855.
And, here we are on page 59,
"On Diffusion" by Dr. Adolf Fick
from Zurich. And it starts off as
you've seen before.
There's a little bit of background.
There is references to the
antecedent literature.
And away we go. 1855: so,
what did he tell us in this
important paper?
Well, let's take a look at his
representation of what's going on in
this process. He was able to
quantify this and give us a measure
that has predictive capacity.
And what he said was that the rate
of ingress expressed by a term
called flux, flux measures the rate
of infusion. It's a mass flow rate.
So, clearly it must have some kind
of units of mass per unit time,
so I'm going to use SI units,
kilograms per second,
but diffusion is quantified on the
basis of unit cross sectional area.
So it's a mass flow rate of species,
i, in, I'm going to make it in one
direction, in the x direction,
the way I've set things up in a
previous sketch.
So, it's kilograms per second on a
unit area a basis.
So, flux is mass flow rate per unit
area. So, the flux of species i,
what he observed is it's related to
the concentration gradient
in species i.
It is the concentration gradient
that dictates the rate of ingress.
Gradient in concentration of i in
the x direction.
Later on, you can generalize this
in three directions.
You can replace the derivative with
the del, and do it with three
dimensions simultaneously.
The constant of proportionality is
D, the diffusion coefficient
or diffusivity.
And, finally, there is a minus sign.
Why? Because species move from
high concentration to low
concentration.
So, if I look at the curve above,
I expect that since the
concentration is high at the free
surface, that the flux is moving
from left to right.
We would expect J sub i to move
from high concentration
to low concentration.
But, look at the slope.
The slope here is negative.
So, in order to have a positive
flux with a negative slope,
we fix it, no problem. Math is easy.
You just put a minus sign.
So, that's the genesis of the minus
sign to make the coordinates come
out properly. And,
units, well, we know the units on
concentration.
Concentration must be in kilograms
per cubic meter.
So, we've got that.
D by dx, the dx, this x actually
calls for a unit.
So, that's one over meter.
And, if I'm going to have kilograms
per square meter per second on the
left, and these are the units of dc
by dx, then it follows that
diffusivity must have units of
length squared per time.
So, diffusivity is expressed in
meters squared per second,
concentration, kilograms per cubic
meter, the derivative one over m,
and the flux in the following units.
But, there's more.
Fick, in this paper,
was so visionary. He said,
you know, this describes diffusion
of matter into matter.
But he says, this also bears a
resemblance, are you ready for this?
I said there are some parallels
between heat transfer and mass
transport. Fick recognized in his
paper that, you know,
this is similar to Fourier's first
law for heat conduction.
He said, look at the parallel.
This is the rate. This is the heat
flux. Instead of a mass flux,
this is heat flux. So, this is
joules per meter squared per second,
goes as minus some thermal
conductivity times the gradient in
temperature. So,
temperature is the potential acting
on heat conduction the way
concentration is the potential
acting on diffusion.
And, this is thermal diffusivity.
And then he says, why stop at two?
Let's go for the hat trick. Let's
go for three. He says,
you know what? This is just like
Ohm's law. This is just like Ohm's
law. Well, you know Ohm's law as V
equals IR. But,
you can write V as minus the
gradient in electrical potential,
minus the gradient in electrical
potential gives you voltage.
And then, I can write instead of
resistance, I can write conductance.
So, I can map that into, since I
know V, V equals minus that.
I can then write Ohm's law as the
current. See,
this is a current.
It's heat flux. This is a current.
It is a mass flux. So, let's write
Ohm's law not with potential as a
function of current. Let's
write current density.
This is amps, which is Coulombs per
second per square meter goes as
minus the conductivity G times d phi
by dx. So, in one paper,
he unifies electron drift,
heat conduction, and mass transport
by diffusion. Not bad,
not bad. And this guy was a medical
doctor.
So, it shows you that knowledge
knows no boundaries.
So, what is diffusion?
Let's define diffusion as mass
transport by random atomic motion.
And, I'll make that point by the
end of the lecture so you'll
understand what it is.
So, what does it tell us so far?
It tells us if we want to increase
the rate of ingress,
remember, we are still running this
doping operation,
I hope you haven't forgotten about
our silicon fab line here.
We're still trying to dope this
with boron. So,
what it's telling us is that if I
want to get a higher flux,
I need to get a higher gradient,
which means I need to have a higher
surface concentration.
So, if I have a higher surface
concentration,
I will increase the flux by
increasing c sub s,
which means increase the pressure of
B2H6.
So, that's good.
But, there's another way we can
increase the rate of ingress.
We can increase the rate of ingress,
we know from experiment,
increase J by increasing temperature.
We saw that with the chemical
kinetics. Well,
where's temperature?
I don't see any temperature effect
here unless you're going to say,
well, concentration is density, and
density is a mild function
of temperature.
No, here's where all the chemistry
is. It's inside the diffusivity
because what's diffusivity going to
be related to?
If it's boron moving through
silicon, diffusivity must be related
to atom mobility.
And, atom mobility must be related
to atom arrangements.
And, what dictates atom
arrangements? Bonding.
And what dictates bonding?
Electronic structure. You see,
chemistry is not just a litany of
silly little laws and rules and
facts. There's a unity here.
So, the chemistry is all contained
in D, and that's also where the
temperature effect is contained.
It should come as no surprise to
you that the temperature dependence
of diffusivity obeys an Arrhenius
type relationship where we have some
pre-exponential,
which instead of A in honor of
Arrhenius is D naught,
they don't honor Arrhenius when they
talk about diffusion.
They just put D naught,
exponential minus Q, not to be
confused with the heat flux.
This is the term that they use: Q
over RT. And,
Q is an activation energy.
It's an activation energy for
diffusion, which means it's an
activation energy for atomic motion.
And, you are normally going to see
it RT. R is simply,
not to be confused with the Rydberg
constant, this is the gas constant,
which is the product of the Avogadro
number and the Boltzmann constant.
You're going to say,
well have I know whether I'm
supposed to put the Boltzmann
constant here or the universal gas
constant? Simple: the exponential
must be dimensionless.
So, if the units of Q are joules
per atom, then you're going to use
the Boltzmann constant.
If the units on Q are joules per
mole, then you're going to
use the gas constant.
Otherwise, you're going to be off by
a mere factor of six times ten to
the 23rd. And,
that should tip you off that
something's wrong because you're
going to get diffusion coefficients
that are either blindingly fast,
you would have atoms moving at a
gazillion times the speed of light,
or you will have five times the
universe to dope the silicon with
the boron. So,
that should tip you off that
something's wrong.
And, as far as typical values go,
Q is on the order of about 2
electron volts or 200 kilojoules per
mole when we're talking about
diffusion in solids.
And, I do want to draw attention,
I mean, clearly when we're talking
about matter moving through matter,
solid, it's got to be diffusion. In
liquids, we can have cooperative
motion, convection,
stirring, but, you can have in
capillaries and narrow fissures,
you can have diffusion in the liquid
state. And, in the case of the
liquid, the value is on the order of
about a tenth of that,
about 0.2 eV, which is about 20
kilojoules per mole in liquids.
So, that will give you some sense.
So that means, if we plot the
natural law of the diffusion
coefficient as a function of the
reciprocal of the absolute
temperature as we saw before with
the Arrhenius plot for the specific
chemical rate constant,
you get a straight line with a
negative slope because high
temperature is to the left.
One over T increases to the right.
And, the slope of this is minus the
value of the activation energy for
diffusion divided by either the
Boltzmann constant or the universal
gas constant. So,
that's the story. Now,
I want to try to give some insight
into what the activation process
must be. What's going on at the
atomistic level that we're trying to
activate? And,
for that, I go to this cartoon.
We see the cartoon showing that
this is now diffusion of metal in a
close packed system.
So, we see an atom with a vacancy
next to it. That's the first thing.
The atom must diffuse into a
vacancy. If there's no vacancy,
the atom can't move. But, we know
there have to be vacancies.
We've already seen from earlier
that it's impossible above zero
Kelvin to have a vacancy free metal,
or solid crystal.
And so, this cartoon shows the atom
moving from the site to the left
jumping into the vacancy,
and eventually occupying the site to
the right. And,
there's a few things good and bad
about this sketch.
Let's look at it from the top.
Forget the bottom. The bottom is
showing you interstitial diffusion.
Let's just focus on the top. First
of all, you've got to have a vacancy.
This is important.
You know that if you watch traffic,
you ever been stuck in traffic? You
are, say, the fourth car back from
the traffic light.
The light turns green.
Then you don't move.
The light turned green.
What's the matter with everybody?
Well, it takes time for the first
car to move to create a vacancy
behind it. And then,
the second car moves, creates a
vacancy behind it.
The third car moves to create a
vacancy in front of you.
So, you drive into car vacancies.
And, you can stand on a bridge
sometime and look at cars pulling
away from a light.
And instead of watching the cars
move, watch the vacancy move
backwards. That's what you have to
have here. If you cease to wait for
the vacancy, then you end up with
what's shown here.
And you see the atoms deforming.
OK, now the atoms don't deform.
This is nuts. This picture is
incorrect. So,
what's really going on?
What's really going on?
This is the lattice at zero Kelvin.
What do we know is going on?
Those atoms are vibrating. So,
we have to consider a pulsating
lattice. And,
we have to understand what the range
of pulsation is.
What's the amplitude of the
pulsation, and what's the frequency
of the pulsation?
OK, so I need frequency,
and I need amplitude. Because the
squishy, these are not Nerf balls.
These are hard spheres. So, this
cartoon is only partly correct.
So, first of all, what's the
pulsation frequency?
Well, this is the vibrational
frequency of a crystal is called the
Debye frequency denoted nu sub D,
the Debye frequency.
And, the Debye frequency at room
temperature is on the order of about
10 trillion per second,
ten to the 13th hertz, ten to the
13th times a second the atoms in all
of us are vibrating.
But, diffusion, if we work
backwards from established data,
we learned that the jump frequency,
in other words, the jump rate, the
jump frequency which is denoted
capital gamma,
is on the order of about 100 million
per second.
So, that's a big number,
but it still 100,000 times smaller
than the Debye frequency.
So, most of the atomic motion is
oscillatory. Most of it is
oscillatory. So,
this is one attempt in ten to the
fifth is successful.
So, this means that even if you
have a vacancy next door,
even if you have a vacancy next door,
you will try 100,
00 times to jump into the vacancy
before you get in.
And what has to happen?
What has to happen is the two atoms
on either side,
the ones that are shown here as
squashed, those two atoms,
at least one of them has to be
moving out at the moment you're
moving in. And,
when that atom moves out at the
moment you try to move it,
you can squeeze through without
having to result to the Nerf ball
model. OK, let's not have any
deformable atoms.
So, that's what we are learning
here, that we have this to wait for.
So, what does this mean?
This means, then, that the
activation energy can be broken into
two components.
First of all, we have to form the
vacancy. So, we've got that.
We learned that earlier when we
studied defects.
So, there is an enthalpy of vacancy
formation. You have to pay for that,
pay to open up a vacancy next door,
and then there's the energy
associated with this fluctuation.
And that's called the enthalpy of
migration, atom migration.
And the first one is related to
bonding because this is really,
in essence, the inverse of the
bonding energy.
And, the second one must be related
to structure. It must be related to
free volume. And,
here's a cute graph that illustrates
this. These are all FCC metals:
lead, aluminum,
silver, gold, copper,
and iron. Iron is both FCC and BCC.
But, we'll put it on the graph for
completeness. And so,
what's plotted here is activation
energy. And, it's a function of
melting temperature,
activation energy as a function of
melting temperature.
Activation energy for diffusion as
a function of the melting point:
well, we know that the melting point
must be related to bond energy.
And, bond energy is related to the
energy of vacancy formation.
So, a low melting metal has a low
activation energy for diffusion.
A high melting metal has a high
bond energy, therefore,
a high vacancy formation energy.
There is such beauty in this graph.
There is completeness here. It
ties everything together.
It's really so elegant.
And, we can also look at diffusion
by an interstitial mechanism.
That's what's shown underneath here,
same idea. The only difference is
with interstitials,
there are so many interstitials,
they exist. We don't have to pay to
form the interstitials.
The interstitials are there by
virtue of the fact that we don't
have 100% packing.
The closest pack structure we have
is FCC. And, that is 74% atomic.
So therefore, it's 26% free volume.
So, we've got 26% to play with,
and it's unlikely we've got
interstitial loading to consume all
of that. So, in the case of
interstitials,
the Q is simply equal to delta H of
migration in the case of
interstitials.
You don't have to pay for formation
of vacancies.
So now, let's get to the question of
random atomic motion.
This is what will convince you that
we have random atomic motion.
Let's look at a really clean
experiment. Let's look at this one.
We talked about radioactivity last
day. Suppose I make a diffusion
sandwich that consists of the
following: I'm going to put cobalt,
cobalt, and cobalt. It's all pure
cobalt. The only difference is the
center of the sandwich is going to
consist of radioactive cobalt.
And, the two layers of bread are
cool cobalt.
So, there's no concentration
gradient here because you know that
radio isotopes behave identically,
chemically. The fact that there's
radioactivity does not affect the
chemical bonding capabilities of
cobalt because it doesn't affect the
electronic structure.
And as far as the mass effect goes,
it's so tiny that it can be
disregarded. So,
what happens over time?
If there's no concentration
gradient, according to Fick,
there should be no diffusion
But what happens,
as this cartoon shows,
if we have a center band here that
consists of a mix of radio cobalt
and regular cobalt,
over time we find that the cobalt is
uniformly distributed throughout the
specimen. And,
if we stop action and measure the
rate of dispersion of cobalt through
the specimen, we find that the rate
is described by Fick's law.
So, we have random jumping at the
atomic level in accordance
with Fick's first law.
So, this is a demonstration that we
have things occurring at the
atomistic level involving random
jumping. And,
to make the case more potent,
the actual curve here obeys a
Gaussian, which is exactly the
random walk problem,
you know, the drunken sailor walks
out the door, takes one step or two
steps, and so the chances that he
gets five steps away are
vanishingly small.
The chances are that he falls after
one or two steps are higher.
So, you will get a Gaussian curve
here for the distance at the cobalt
has gone as a function of time.
So, what's wrong with this cartoon,
by the way? We've talked about this
is cobalt jumping through cobalt.
Where does cobalt have to jump to?
It has to jump into a vacancy. I
don't see any vacancies here.
So, the chances of this cobalt
jumping and exchanging with the
adjacent cobalt,
now we're not talking about a tiny
fluctuation to allow cobalt to
squirt into a vacancy.
We are talking about a fluctuation
like this to allow two cobalts to
crisscross. And,
I mean, that's just not going to
happen, maybe once in the life of
the universe. But I don't think
it's going to happen.
So, we really need to have
vacancies in here.
And, ultimately we have to recognize
that diffusion is heavily influenced
by defects: no vacancies,
poor diffusion. Many vacancies,
better diffusion. So, let's take a
look at some evidence of this.
This is a plot of diffusion
coefficient is a function of
temperature. It's an Arrhenius plot
in accordance with this curve here.
And what we have is for a variety
of impurities in solid iron.
So, let's look up at the top here.
This is hydrogen. And you can see
that the diffusivity of hydrogen
increases with temperature up to the
temperature at which iron converts
from BCC to FCC,
and then there's an abrupt drop in
the diffusivity of hydrogen.
What's happening? What's happening?
What's the void fraction of BCC
versus the void fraction of FCC?
FCC is more tightly packed, and so
we see an abrupt fall.
Here's carbon; same thing.
The diffusivity rises up to the
transformation temperature,
falls, and then continues to rise.
And, note the difference in the
slope. The slope of carbon in BCC
iron is gentler than the slope of
carbon in FCC iron.
Well, what's that mean?
It means that the slope in FCC iron
is this upper value.
The slope in BCC iron is the lower
value.
You don't have to pay for the
formation of vacancies.
Here's the self diffusion of iron
in iron. Look,
it drops two orders of magnitude
when it moves from BCC to FCC.
And, just to make the point, this
is carbon in graphite.
This is self diffusion of carbon in
graphite. What's the problem there?
Where do we see that as operating?
Well, we said that delta H vacancy
formation is related to bonding.
So, here you see the comparison
between metallic bonding,
which is what you have in iron,
so self diffusion of iron if I were
to project this curve up to the
temperature, so we can compare at
the same temperature,
we see seven, eight orders of
magnitude difference between self
diffusion of iron in iron.
That's a metal in a metallic crystal,
versus carbon in graphite,
which is carbon in a covalent
crystal. So: big difference in
performance. Now,
there are other ways of looking at
it.
Let's look at other defects.
How do other defects affect?
So, here's a cartoon showing the
diffusion of some solute into a
material, only this is a real
material. It's a polycrystalline
material. So,
there is a grain boundary.
And, as you know, grain boundaries
have a little more openness.
The atoms at the grain boundary
have fewer nearest neighbors.
Well, if what you are trying to do
is to jump to that little narrow
saddle point waiting for those atoms
to pulsate, in a grain boundary,
you don't have to wait.
The atoms are farther apart.
So, it's like the difference
between having to drive down an
expressway, or drive down a narrow
city street. You've got a much
easier time moving quickly down the
expressway. All right,
so we can see what the cartoon is
trying to show is that up at the top,
we see the rate of ingress of this
solute through the bulk,
or we say it is lattice diffusion,
classical lattice diffusion. Down
the grain boundary,
at the same time, we see a much
deeper penetration because the
material is able to move
with less constraint.
And, along the surface,
it can move very readily.
Surface diffusion is very,
very rapid. And, here's some data.
These are three different
investigations of diffusion of
silver, self diffusion.
OK, this is silver diffusing
through silver.
So, this is classical.
What they call volume diffusion is
what we would call lattice diffusion
or bulk diffusion,
single crystal, silver moving
through silver.
How would you make these
measurements? What's the only way
you could identify one silver from
another? You have to use radio
tracer. OK, so using radio tracer,
they're able to get self diffusion
coefficients, and you see,
what they've done is they've flipped
this around. This is very wimpy.
This is so wimpy; look at what
they've done. These people,
the people that plotted this,
they're such sissies. Look, do you
have any trouble figuring out that
temperature is increasing in this
direction? I mean,
you can think in one over T space.
This is how I feel comfortable.
Why look in an Arrhenius plot, I
want a negative slope and a straight
line. And, what they did is look at
the numbers. See the numbers?
They're ascending from right to
left because they're so chicken that
they're afraid to have temperature
rising from right to left.
So, what they did is they plotted
the diffusion coefficient,
natural log of the diffusion
coefficient. But,
they've got one over T rising from
right to left so that they'll get
positive looking slopes
on their lines.
It's very girly.
I don't like this.
I don't like this. OK,
so look at this. Now, here we have,
first of all, a very steep slope.
So, that indicates a higher
activation energy because we have a
higher lattice energy with which we
have to deal. Here's the grain
boundary. The grain boundary,
first of all, it's several orders of
magnitude higher,
and the slope is gentler,
indicating that we have less
constraint. And,
finally up at the top,
we have the surface diffusion which
has, and I draw your attention
to the values.
Here, we are down to around ten to
the minus eight,
ten to the minus nine,
ten to the minus ten in units of
centimeters squared per second.
Look at the surface diffusion. Ten
to the minus five,
ten to the minus four,
here's diffusion in molten ferrous
alloys, ten to the minus five,
ten to the minus four. So, what
we've got here is diffusion across
the surface is on a par with
diffusion in a liquid.
So, it gives you a very vivid
demonstration of how there's a
relationship between the physical
constraints of the lattice and
diffusion coefficients.
So, we can capture that by saying
that the activation energy for what
I've been calling bulk diffusion or
lattice diffusion,
this is classical vacancy stuff,
OK?
Vacancy mechanism,
OK, via vacancy, this activation
energy is much greater than the
activation energy for diffusion
along grain boundaries,
which is much greater than the
activation energy across a free
surface. So, what do we see?
The trend in moving from left to
right is decreasing coordination
number, which means more freedom.
And, as Q goes down,
the value of D goes up.
So, all other things being equal,
this is for, let's compare apples to
apples. So, this is for
self-diffusion,
silver in silver,
iron in iron, what have you,
the diffusion coefficient for
lattice diffusion is going to be
less than the diffusion coefficient
for grain boundary diffusion which
is less than the diffusion
coefficient for surface diffusion.
And so, things are making sense.
And finally, to make the point, it
even applies in amorphous solids.
So, I want to show you some data.
This is helium entering different
glasses. We just finished the unit
on glasses. So,
let's put it all together.
So, what people have done here is
measure, they're using a permeation
velocity. For all intents and
purposes, the ordinate is
proportional to the diffusion
coefficient. So: high permeation
velocity, a high value of
permittivity, K,
is the same as high value of D,
diffusivity.
And, what do you find?
First of all: Arrhenius type
behavior, and secondly you see the
most rapid infusion of helium is
with fused silica,
Vycor. As we come down here,
we see more and more modification.
Down here we have soda lime glass.
So, let's pick a constant
temperature, let's say,
200. Fused silica is strictly
network former.
Borosilicate has network former plus
some borate intermediate.
Down here, we have soda lime,
which consists of network former
plus a fair bit of sodium oxide.
So, the chain lengths are getting
shorter. We have tighter packing.
The void space is smaller. And,
down here, we have lead borate.
Lead borate has a huge amount of
modification. It's a euphemism
for crystal.
So, we have lead crystal down here.
We have amorphous silica here. At
constant temperature,
we can see this is ten to the minus
eight. This is ten to the minus 14,
a million times difference in the
coefficient for helium entering the
glasses at the same temperature.
So, again, the message is, as the
channel is less and less constrained,
you have a higher and higher rate of
diffusion. And so,
what they did here is they plotted,
as a function of the amount of,
these are all network formers.
So, as the fraction of network
formers rises,
you get a more open structure.
As the fraction of network formers
falls, that's to say the chain
lengths are getting shorter.
You've got tighter packing. So,
this is beautiful. It's an isotherm
showing the rate of helium ingress
as a function of amount of network
formation. And,
here's the last one I'll show you.
I couldn't resist. These are so
beautiful. Look at this.
This is now the same glass,
but instead of asking, what's the
rate of helium?
Let's compare: same glass,
same structure; what's the rate of
helium ingress,
neon ingress, nitrogen ingress,
and what do you find?
The larger the species.
And, this is H, but in fact it's H2.
So, what do you find?
The larger the species,
the greater the activation energy
for ingress of the species into the
same glass. So,
this is changing the size of the
diffuser and keeping the size of the
channel constant.
This one here was keeping the size
of the diffuser constant,
and changing the size of the channel.
So, everything is making sense.
So, I wanted to give you an example
showing how the catalyst works.
And so, I'd like to talk about
catalytic converters in automobiles.
This is the number one market for
industrial catalysts:
catalytic converters.
A little bit of background.
Gasoline is a mix of hydrocarbons,
but the dominant one is octane here:
C8H18, which we burn with air.
And air, of course, is only 20%
oxygen. It's roughly 80% nitrogen.
So, when we burn gasoline, we make
not just water vapor,
carbon monoxide, carbon dioxide,
but the air at those temperatures
forms various nitrous oxides.
And these are, in fact, the
precursor to smog.
So, back in the early 70's,
it was decided that in order to
improve urban air quality,
we need to convert unburned
hydrocarbons. Some of the gasoline
actually doesn't end up being burned.
And, some of it's completely burned
to carbon monoxide.
And, of course, there's nitrous
oxide. So, here's what the mandate
was: to convert the hydrocarbons to
water vapor and carbon dioxide.
I know carbon dioxide is implicated
in greenhouse gases,
but believe me, if you've got a
choice of carbon monoxide or carbon
dioxide, I recommend you
go with carbon dioxide.
So, we'll solve the small problems
first. And then,
nitrous oxides convert then to
nitrogen, oxygen,
and CO2. Now, look at the nature of
these three reactions.
The first two involve oxidation
reactions. The last one involves a
reduction reaction.
Now, if I told you I want to make a
single reactor in which you should
simultaneously conduct three
different chemical conversions,
two of which are reductions, and one
of which is an oxidation,
in the same place at the same time,
you would say, you're nuts.
You can't do that.
Well, that's the challenge that was
presented to the auto industry.
And, on top of that, some pinhead
in the government decided to invoke
the Sherman Antitrust Act,
which was designed to prevent people
from colluding on price-fixing.
But they invoked it in colluding on
technological developments.
So, all of the auto companies were
obliged to work independently.
So, GM, and Ford,
and Chrysler, couldn't pool their
resources. GM alone tried 1,
00 formulations. Why did they try 1,
00? Because people don't understand
the basis science of catalysis.
And, when you don't understand,
there's only one way to proceed.
It's called by inspection,
cook and look. It's very costly.
And, finally, this is what they
settled on: platinum palladium for
the first two reactions,
and rhodium for the last one.
Basically, you go to the most
expensive part of the
periodic table.
And, that's the formulation.
Tom, if we could go to the document
camera, this catalyst is put on a
substrate. So,
we want to use as little of the
precious metals as possible because
it's a surface reaction.
What's happening is the catalyst is
sitting here. So,
this is platinum, rhodium,
and palladium. And, what happens is
it provides a site for selectivity,
absorption of CO's.
So, CO's can absorb as follows as
opposed to in the gas phase,
two of these molecules are zooming
along at high speed.
And, it's not good enough for them
to just collide.
They actually have to be close
enough together for a long enough
period of time for bonds to decay
and form. If we adsorb,
they can sit side by side long
enough for something to do this.
And then they have to desorb.
You have to adsorb the reactants and
desorb the products.
So, this is now a ceramic catalyst.
You can see it's been extruded like
pasta and then fired.
So, all up and down these honeycomb
channels, we put a dilute wash of
acids containing platinum,
rhodium, palladium, fire because we
want the thinnest,
thinnest layer of the precious metal
all up and down this ceramic
catalyst. So, that's what's inside.
If you look up underneath the car,
you'll see the exhaust tubing, and
it will flare out to something about
this size. And then,
it goes on to the muffler.
So, this is the three-way catalytic
converter. And then,
Tom, could we go back to the
computer, please?
And then, hand and glove with this
came unleaded gasoline.
We couldn't have catalytic
converters with leaded gasoline
because leaded gasoline contains,
as the name implies, lead as
tetraethyl lead shown here with this
compound. And,
one of the combustion products is
lead oxide.
Well, lead oxide you've met before.
It's a modifier. But, it's also
volatile. It's volatile.
So, it will go down through the
exhaust stream to the catalytic
converter. And,
it is converted as NOX is to
elemental lead.
And then, it decomposes.
So, now you have elemental lead,
and elemental lead alloys with
platinum, palladium,
and rhodium. Now, what do you think
the catalytic value of lead is?
Well, let me tell you.
Given the difference in price
between these three and this,
if this had any catalytic value,
we wouldn't be using these. So,
what this does is it poisons the
catalyst, and after several
tank-fulls of gas,
renders the catalyst useless.
So, the advent of the three-way
catalytic converter was accompanied
by the advent of unleaded gasoline.
Have a nice weekend.